the division between palestine's two
political factions played out in the
streets of nablis on Wednesday
Security Forces attacked mourners in the
funeral procession of a Hamas gunman
[Music]
officials say some participants violated
Arrangements that were agreed before the
funeral but many here believe the
Palestinian Authority does not want
Hamas to have a strong presence in the
occupied West Bank
not only is the Israeli Army worried
about the fighters uniting Palestinians
who have personal interests are worried
about the unity in Janine being copied
in other places
before he was killed gunman Abdul fatah
was taking refuge in Janine a hub for
the armed resistance to Israel's
occupation
here in Janine a different picture not
only do Palestinians fight side by side
but gunman provides support to one
another even when they belong to
different Palestinian factions and come
from different cities Fighters the
internal Palestinian division only
serves to benefit Israel
the leadership's far away from the
Palestinian struggle for a long time the
Palestinian Authority wants to curb the
resistance and we're against that
is one of six Palestinians Israeli
forces killed during the late
engineering on Tuesday
he was a member of the Palestinian
Security Forces before he took up arms
and joined other fighters in Janine
now is the time for us to take up arms
young people have much more awareness
they say we have to resist we can't stay
silent against the Israeli aggression
for Palestinians it's been a cycle of
grief anger and Mourning
United in pain and now they say the
fight
Ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied West
Bank